ma mère mes frères sont là vincent
calédonie il était il vivant aujourd'hui
en martinique mais leur coeur est
partagé
certains sont nés en calédonie d'autres
y ont grandi et vécu des décennies
emmenés par leurs parents dans les
années 60 lors du boom du nickel cette
nuit et ils ont suivi très tard le
déroulement du référendum
je me disais effectivement est ce que le
oui ou le non l'emporterait ce qui fait
que par rapport aux scores serrés
ça m'a vraiment tenu en haleine c'est
pourquoi je suis resté vraiment dix ans
j'étais vraiment accroché au cou par les
deux de télévision et en parallèle
j'écoute effectivement l'évolution de la
situation sera jo jo dan le braqueur
devenu le coeur palpite on se dit bon on
a vécu quand même plus de 22 en nouvelle
calédonie comment ne pas avoir laissé
une partie de soi là bas donc forcément
on pense à ce qui se passe ce qu'a été
ce qu'on a vécu et qui ce qu'est ce qui
va se passer de la entier de calédonie
les kanaks les surnommait à l'époque
affectueusement les sacs à houlé c'est
aujourd'hui le nom de leur association
qui organise des voyages là bas car tous
y ont encore une partie de leur famille
j'ai moins bien que l'acaa données ne
sera pas indépendant vous parce que bon
bah c'est comme je dis c'est mon
deuxième chez moi et j'aimerais bien
pouvoir y retourner en tout temps de
crise tranquillité chaque fois c'était
ma toute ma famille et je suis la seule
à être en martinique en majorité leur
coeur penche pour le maintien de la
calédonie dans l'ensemble national mais
raziel à penser autrement
né là bas elle a vécu comme les autres
les événements des années 80 les
couvre-feux la répression militaire
parti à 7 ans avec ses parents qui
fuyaient la sécurité elle veut croire
aujourd'hui un pays qui s'appellera la
kanaky c'est leur terre c'est chez eux
beaucoup sont venus ils ont se sont
octroyés des zones c les plus belles
zones et on les a remis dans l'est dans
les forêts on les a retranché
ils se sont retranchés parce que le
l'étranger venait s'installer mais ils
ont de quoi beau saison au camp mais il
faut qu'ils évoluent un petit peu plus
encore dans ce qu'on appelle le social
quelle que soit leur opinion c'est
martinique et se sentent calédonien au
même titre que tous ces gens venus
d'ailleurs polynésiens javanais
wallisien un grand brassage ethnique qui
avec le métissage fait de l'archipel une
société de plus en plus diverse et
complexe